this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
professional or just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace check out their amazing all
in one platform through the link in the
description below more on them in a bit
today's protagonist grew up as a
destitute child in victorian england
fueled by a thirst for knowledge and
self-improvement he turned to books for
companionship and to writing as a means
of fostering his ideas during those
lonely days two fears burrowed deep into
his mind that he would never become
famous and then he would die virgin if
we could use the titular invention from
one of his novels we'd go back in time
to reassure the boy we tell him have
faith bertie your books are to sell in
the millions your ideas will influence
generations of writers and even help
shape society and don't worry about
another thing you'll see plenty of
action welcome to today's biographics in
which we'll learn about the life works
and loves of herbert george wells one of
the fathers of modern science fiction
herbert george wells was born on the
21st of september 1866 in bromley kent
in england youngest of four children the
whole family referred to him as bertie
his father was joseph known as joe a
former gardener and professional
cricketer now turned shopkeeper mother
sarah had been a ladies maid before
marrying joe and founding their
unsuccessful business venture atlas
house shop selling chinaware and
sporting goods joe and sarah did not
have a happy marriage financial woes
only added to the discord which grew
naturally out of the differences of
character sarah was anxious to out and
inclined to pessimism joe was
irresponsible and allegedly a
philanderer but he was also an
irredeemable optimist who believed in
personal growth in later life welles's
character and worldview would swing
between the two extremes but as a
schoolboy he sided squarely with team
joe adopting an optimistic attitude and
diving headlong into study and
self-improvement he had read voraciously
from an early age especially when a
broken leg immobilized him at the age of
seven at the age of 13 he had written
his first complete work the desert daisy
a humorous comic strip all the while
excelling in his studies at the brony
academy at private school but as he
turned 14 joe and sarah could not afford
the school fees any longer bertie and
his two elder brothers were sent into
the world as apprentices with a draper
bertie was fired by his first employer
and joined sarah in upper house west
sussex having separated from joe she
became the housekeeper of this
upperclass residence here bertie took to
studying latin and science's necessary
steps to become a chemist apprentice
needless to say he excelled in all
scientific subjects but there was a
catch the pharmacist who was going to
employ him was not going to offer him a
salary worse still he expected payment
to have wells as an apprentice neither
parent could afford this so bertie had
to return to a business he hated drapery
from 1881 to 1883 he loathed every
minute he spent at hyde's drapery
emporium in south sea hampshire bertie
worked 13-hour days slept in a crowded
dormitory with the other apprentices and
endured constant bullying by the shop
manager but he never gave up on his
studies vowing to dedicate all of his
spare time to studying after two years
of this rigorous routine he received an
offer to join midhearst grammar school
west sussex as a student and teacher's
assistant by september of 1883 bertie
was rid of drapery and ready to start at
midhearst but it came at a price to
leave the apprenticeship hyde's emporium
demanded a fee which sarah paid by
draining her life savings was it a good
investment well it appears so as bertie
thrived in an academic environment in
1884 he entered the normal school of
science in london attending the biology
class of t.h huxley a vocal supporter of
darwinism thanks to his good grades
bertie had obtained a government
scholarship for trainee teachers and was
set on to the next stage of his life
[Music]
bertie loved huxley's biology and
zoology lessons the influence of which
would be found in his latter works but
after his favorite professor fell ill
bertie realized that the rest of the
faculty was not up to scratch after a
brilliant first year the young wells
gradually neglected his studies plunging
into extracurricular activities he
dedicated most of his time to literature
and politics preaching socialism at
student debating societies and
attracting a circle of open-minded
rebellious students with the help he
founded the science schools journal
which became a vehicle for his first
efforts at scientific romance the genre
that we now call science fiction one of
these was the chronic argonauts the
first incarnation of what would later
become the time machine with all that
going on who had the time to study or
not bertie in the summer of 1887 he
failed his final geology exam and left
the normal school of science without a
degree luckily wells landed on his feet
and secured a teaching post at halt
academy in wales during his brief time
there he enjoyed the occasional game of
football or soccer with his pupils but
during one of these matches a people
tackled well so badly that he suffered
from a crushed kidney and a lung
hemorrhage to top it all off the young
teacher was also diagnosed with
tuberculosis and had to leave his job
wells joined his mother at the uppark
residence to recuperate and was once
again fit for work in autumn of 1888.
this is when his teaching career
properly took off wells taught science
at the henley house school in london
this small institution had only 13
pupils one of which was a.a milne the
future creator of winnie the pooh wells
also resumed his university studies
earning his bachelor in sciences in 1890
were the first class in zoology and a
second in geology but the big event of
this period was that wells had fallen in
love and she loved him back her name was
isabelle mary wells apparently it wasn't
only royals and aristocrats who married
amongst cousins bertie and isabelle
married on october 30th 1891 and moved
to the london borough of wandsworth in
addition to teaching he took on
additional writing jobs mainly for
scientific and educational publications
welles's textbook of biology published
in 1893 remained in use for the next 30
years in 1891 wells health deteriorated
again most likely due to another bout of
tb he had to give up teaching again
relying entirely on freelance writing to
support isabella himself luckily welles
had struck gold with a winning formula
alright we'll get back to today's video
in just a moment but first here's a word
from today's video sponsor squarespace
this is the age of creation everyone is
on the internet making something you've
either got a great idea yourself or you
probably know someone who does and when
it's time to move that project from your
head to the screen in front of you
that's where squarespace comes in it's
the perfect web tool to help you fashion
the internet into whatever you want it
to be maybe the hands-on type you've got
lots of opinions and ideas about what
exactly your website should look like if
so very cool squarespace gives you all
the customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical bs to worry about or maybe you
just need something that's functional
something that works with minimal
thought so you can stay focused on the
content and not the coat of paint well
just use one of their quick beautiful
templates to make a website that's both
fresh and simple and once you're done
setting up your website locking in the
name maybe playing with some of the
colors there are so many extra features
that squarespace provides so that your
website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member only areas analytics commercial
options 20 customer support everything
you never want in one place so when
you're ready to get started on the next
project of yours big or small if
involves a website it's got to be with
squarespace right now you can go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your new
site go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain
and let's get back into it
after some of his rigorous scientific
articles had been rejected by publishers
he returned to the genre of scientific
romance which he expressed in the form
of adventurous short stories and
prophetic writings on the future of
society the late victorian period had a
thirst for adventurous tales which
combined wild imagination and plausible
science in the wake of french author
jules verne and welles would give them
just what they needed with his first
novel the time machine published in
1895. welles is unnamed time traveler
hops to the year 802 701 thanks to his
invention the future society appears to
be a utopia in which the descendants of
humans the eloy live free from labor and
from need inside communal accommodation
but the traveler soon finds out that the
eloy live in constant fear of the
brutish morlocks who live underground
performing all menial tasks needed to
keep society going the warlocks also
descendants of the human race crawl out
at night to feast on the passive illoy
the traveler speculates that the class
divide between the rich and the poor in
the future has become so extreme that
they've evolved into separate species
according to matthew taunton lecturer at
the university of east anglia the
author's intention was to portray a
socialism gone wrong where the
cannibalistic proletariat prey on the
effete aristocracy it's an interesting
point as wells was and always remained a
proponent of socialism pushing for broad
societal reforms and yet he seemed to
issue some early warnings about the
dangers of violent revolutionary change
the success of the time machine was
followed by a surge of creativity
between 1896 and 1901 the author
completed some of his best-known novels
the island of dr moreau the invisible
man the war of the worlds and the first
men in the moon we'd love to spend a few
words on each one of these and other
masterpieces but time and word counts
are
ruthless tyrants luckily you can read
most of welles's productions for free
online i'll only focus on one today the
war of the worlds this is the book that
set the blueprint for alien invasion
fiction in a few words a martian landing
party flies to earth massacring and
destroying everything in their path
humanity is defenseless until jeff
goldblum and will smith hacking to the
alien internet with a computer virus so
no
not this one the original plot line came
from bertie's brother frank while
trekking across surrey and kent frank
remar suppose some beings from another
planet were to drop out of the sky
suddenly wells combined frank's
suggestion with the popular genre in the
victorian period invasion literature
novels like the battle of dorking
depicted the british military fighting
the invasion of technologically superior
enemies for example the german second
reich or a franco-russian alliance
formidable enemies but still human
enemies nonetheless welles imagines the
landing of an unstoppable
extraterrestrial force wielding weapons
of mass destruction beyond anything
humanity had demised thus far what
really strikes home is that the invasion
is not described from the point of view
of a politician a scientist or a
military leader in some large city as it
would become a later staple of the genre
no welles's unnamed protagonist is just
some ordinary joe who resides in the
leafy middle class slightly boring
surrey suburbia a countryside permeated
by the most visible and desirable
consequences of colonialism and
imperialism technological advance wealth
railways but it takes only for a
mysterious cylinder to land and the top
superpower of the time great britain
becomes a victim of ruthless colonizers
the success of his scientific romance
novels brought wealth and recognition to
mr wells but he had loftier ambitions he
craved recognition as a serious
intellectual so in the early years of
the 20th century the author directed his
efforts towards a series of
semi-autobiographical novels and social
essays in which he forecasted a
desirable future for humanity love and
mr lewisham published in 1900 draws
heavily from wells's own life and
experiences the protagonist mr lewisham
is an impoverished yet ambitious science
teacher with grand plans to climb the
social ladder these plans are largely
thrown into the wind when he's
distracted by a passionate on-and-off
relationship with a beautiful ethor
henderson they eventually barry although
their relationship is complicated by the
shenanigans of ethel's stepfather a
mystic medium and con man eventually
lewisham must admit defeat his plans for
a brighter future will never come to
fruition bitterly he concludes the
future what are we
of us but servants or traitors to that
the novel kips of 1905 contains yet more
autobiographical elements the titular
character is adopted by a couple of
shopkeepers in kent and is later
apprenticed to a draper when kips
inherits a fortune from a long-lost
grandfather he has to negotiate the
complex rules of the english class
system as you may have inferred social
mobility and class relations are
recurring topics of welles's appearing
also in his futuristic social writings
such as anticipations of 1901 and a
modern utopia of 1905. in his
anticipations wells predicted a world
unified into a single state at peace
with itself rationally governed by a
middle class of scientists most
languages will disappear with only
english french and chinese being spoken
by future societies these will be split
into four classes a shareholding class
at the top a productive middle class of
mechanics and engineers a non-productive
middle class of clerks and mid-level
managers and finally the abyss people
without property nor clear role in the
functioning of society taking a dark
turn wells indicates that a successful
world government is the one who educates
sterilizes exports or poisons its people
of the abyss in other words
eugenics a concept which the writer
thankfully abandoned shortly thereafter
during those years wells did not abandon
science fiction completely in the early
1900s his scientific romances explored
the potential of military technology on
the evolution of society a short story
the land iron clans of 1903 introduces
the concept of an armored all-terrain
fighting vehicle winston churchill later
claimed that this story inspired the
creation of the tank his later novels
the war in the air and the world set
free prophesies the introduction of
long-range air bombing raids and even
atomic weapons in both works the use of
these weapons brings about a total
collapse of society but in the world set
free this is followed by the creation of
a new peaceful and prosperous world
order in which all nations submit to a
single government welles's growing fame
attracted the attention of the fabian
society a group of socialist
intellectuals proponents of gradual
social reform leading figures included
playwright george bernard shaw and
founders of the london school of
economics beatrice and sydney webb in
1903 they invited wells to join their
ranks but he soon disagreed with them he
accused the society of being little more
than a debate club for middle class
socialists who lacked the drive for real
change from their side the fabians were
quick to retaliate attacking wells
because of his promiscuous and immoral
love life
based on the last section mr wells may
appear as someone who was married to his
writing desk they did sire many children
after all but the ulcer was not devoid
of carnal passion far from it in fact
his lust for pleasures of the flesh
eventually alienated his wife isabelle
who simply did not have the same taste
for conjugal visits according to wells
isabel thought that lovemaking was
nothing more than an outrage inflicted
upon reluctant womankind surely after
marrying isabelle wells had already
started a relationship with a student of
his amy catherine robbins whom he called
jane jane and bertie moved in together
in january 1984 wells obtained a divorce
from isabel exactly one year later and
the new couple married on the 27th of
october 1895. the couple went on to have
two sons george phillip and frank
richard while jane was pregnant with
george wells argued that her body and
overall health were too fragile to
withstand his amorous requests in other
words bertie claimed the right to sleep
around with other women whilst jane was
expecting and it seems like jane was
happy with the setup between 1895 and
1914 wells had frequent affairs with
students writers and journalists seduced
by his blue eyes and magnetic rhetoric
the most notable lover was a young
cambridge student and fabian member
amber reeves when wells learned that
amber was expecting his child he
hurriedly arranged for her to marry a
young barrister george rivers blanco
white at that time wells was trying to
rest control of the fabian society off
george byrne and shaw's hands when in
1908 news spread of the affair and the
questionable arrangement the writer was
expelled from the society as usual jane
was an incredibly patient wife even
welcoming amber into the family life and
helping her buy baby clothes their baby
daughter anna jane would be acknowledged
by wells only in 1929. the next love of
wells life was a feminist journalist
sicily isabelle fairfield she was also
known as rebecca west west attracted
wells's attention with one of her
scathing reviews and attention which
turned a friendship which turned to an
affair in late 1913 rebecca borber to
her son anthony west on august 4th 1914
[Music]
just as baby anthony cried his way into
life great britain was declaring war on
germany world war one was breaking out a
conflict that would see many of wells's
most deadly anticipations leap from the
page into reality the writer was not a
pacifist he wrote a series of passionate
articles blaming squarely the central
empires for plunging the world into
deadly chaos only their defeat could put
an end to widespread militarism and
restore lasting peace on earth these
articles were later collected in the
volume the war that will end the war in
1914 a book which popularized the phrase
the war to end all wars coined by wells
but later attributed to u.s president
woodrow wilson wells was too old to join
the fight of course but he did serve the
war effort in 1918 he was recruited by
the ministry of propaganda where his
duty was to draft the war aims of the
triple taunt as a supporter of a unified
world government to ensure peace wells
included among these aims the setting up
of the league of nations in the interwar
years this organization proved largely
ineffective and its chief proponent
became one of its worst critics not an
uncommon pattern in wells's life for
example in september and october of 1920
the writer traveled to moscow to meet
lenin and trotsky while initially
impressed by the pragmatic energetic
action of the bolsheviks he later
described russia as a country nearing a
state of total collapse in the same year
wells published another non-fiction work
the outline of history his aim was to
describe the whole of human history and
how humanity had evolved since its
inception the underlying subtext was
that the key to peace progress and
security were neither nationalism nor
revolution but rather education the
outline of history proved incredibly
popular bringing wells new fame and
plenty of face time with world leaders
throughout the 1920s and 1930s for
example in 1934 he met with franklin d
roosevelt and later got to interview
joseph stalin for the magazine the new
statesman the writer was not impressed
by the soviet leader's mental acumen
writing that he has little of the quick
uptake of president roosevelt and none
of the subtlety and tenacity of lenin
his was not a free impulsive brain or a
scientifically organized brain it was a
trained leninist marxist brain the two
disagreed on the present and future of
capitalism according to wells it was a
doomed system which needed to be
reformed peacefully to achieve economic
justice for all classes while stalin
believed that capitalism was still too
strong and needed to be violently torn
down despite their differences wells
left the interview with an overall
positive impression of the georgian
dictator i've never met a man more fair
candid and honest whilst dabbling in the
world's current affairs bertie did not
neglect his more private affairs it
parted ways with rebecca west in 1923
and his long-suffering wife jane died of
cancer in 1927 but the sprightly 61 year
old still yearned for love and quickly
started a new relationship with 22 year
old dutch socialist adet kuhn when the
affair ended a few years later bertie
rekindled his acquaintance with an old
flame russian baroness maura bumberg
mora was an interesting character who
had been involved in a failed plot to
overthrow lenin and may have also been
an informant for the bolshevik secret
police the checker the two had met in
1920 during wells's visit to moscow
maura at the time was the mistress of
political activist maxim gorky but
bertie did not seem to mind while they
spent a torrid night of love together
moira reached london in 1933 and the two
became a permanent item wells proposed
to budberg several times unsuccessfully
nonetheless the baroness remained by his
side until his final days in that same
year the author published his next great
piece of speculative fiction the shape
of things to come the book depicts a
future second world war kicked off by a
nazi invasion of poland pression
the planet descends into chaos barbarity
and further wars until humanity is
rescued by an organization of air pilots
they establish a worldwide government
the benevolent dictatorship of the air
which promotes science wipes out
religion and initiates the path to a
utopian society wells even adapted the
novel into the script of the movie
things to come directed by william
cameron menzies in 1936. only three
years later truth proved again to be
almost on par with fiction when world
war ii broke out the aging wells was
distraught and dismayed by the nation's
will to tear each other apart
understandably his outlook on the future
of mankind was bleak this would be
reflected in his last published work
mind at the end of its tether of 1945.
the short book predicts the inevitable
end of humanity doomed to extinction due
to its inability to control its own
destructive progress nonetheless the
author still maintained a glimmer of
hope which he poured into a grand
project the drafting of an international
charter of human rights his persistent
effort to attract attention on the issue
eventually led to the universal
declaration of human rights adopted by
the united nations in 1948.
unfortunately it'd never reap the
deserved acclaim for his project on the
13th of august 1946 one month before his
80th birthday herbert george wells died
in his sleep he had wished for his
epitaph to be i told you so your damn
fools but no words were engraved on his
headstone in fact he did not get one h.g
wells was cremated and his ashes
scattered from an airplane a fitting end
now just before you leave today maybe
looking for something else to watch why
not check out my new channel called wara
graphics want to know all of the details
about some of history's most famous
battles and wars come join me on war of
graphics from sherman's march to the sea
to operation barbarossa it's got people
fighting each other or occasionally
animals we will cover it there is a link
below